and for the best achievement in
documentary short subjects the nominees
are Arthur and Lily John LC Steve Kovacs
and Christine Samuelson producers the
end of the game Claire Wilbur and Robin
Lehman
billions of years ahead of man Manfred
buyer producer probes in space
George bkc producer whistling Smith
Barry Howells and Michael Scott
producers and the winner is
I've always wanted to say that and the
winner is
Wow they have told me that the talent of
a producer lies in the talents the
producer selects to work with and I
think I showed the producers talent when
I picked Robin Lehmann to work with
anyway it's a little difficult to have
an idea you know come up with an idea to
make a film it's even more difficult to
make that film the worst problem of all
is to find out what's wrong with the
film and this lady helps me find out
what's wrong with it I hold her thanks I
would like to thank the Academy and all
of those who work so hard to make this
all happen and to make this all glitter
thank you very much